- Not cool.
(laughter)
(soft pop music)
I mean I remember doing photo shoots
I'm like what do I do with my hands
I can't like, do they go here?
It was just very just unusual and kind of
having people run up to you and be like
loving me without ever having met me.
It's out love you know and it's out
of and it makes you feel
great and I just thought
talking to my fans, I
feel like they do know me
because we share some many
of those same emotions
you know, it's really cool.
Just walk up to somebody you think is cute
and tell them they're cute.
I was on a sailboat in Nicaragua
and saw these dolphins pass by and we're
listening to some Pitbull, awesome song
that I can't remember, I started writing
another song over that
and it's called Bitches
and it's not out yet, that
turned into a great song.
(upbeat pop music)
I was running late to
a show there was going
to play with my keyboard
player just acoustic,
David Bowie and Britney
Spears were opening for me,
but I never made it so I got there,
it was already over and I remember my
keyboard player Der Gusa was looking at me
very with a lot of disappointment
and I had no excuse, I don't even know
when I was late so that was a good one.
Lollapalooza, not this
summer but the summer before.
I remember that setup, I just had two
of my best friends from Sweden were there
and they were just like what is happening
it was just so cool and I almost burned
my feet because I decided to be barefoot
and the stage was just like so hot for me
in the sun so I had to run and grab
my friend's just like old grandma slippers
that she was wearing and like,
it was just the best
rhyme and everyone was
just singing along and dancing
and the sun was shining
and yeah it was amazing.
(pop music)
Don't let anyone think
that you can't do something
because you're a woman, don't apologize
for yourself and just like
whatever you're feeling
it's right like no one can tell you
that your gut feeling is wrong
and stay true to yourself,
speed that act and have fun.
Take them seriously.
People ask me online all the bad ass girls
that are just keeling
into music right now,
a really really great first kiss,
a good beard, good tits.